- It was recently announced, Nick,
that Ariana is now coming,
and she's gonna take
your seat next season,
so here is the reason why I ask.
- What?
- Do you have--
- Wait a minute!
- What?
- Exactly, exactly.
- Wait a minute!
- It's just this season.
So like, here is my question though,
do you have any advice for her?
- No, I mean, Ariana, as we all know,
is one of the best singers in the game,
and she's gonna be an incredible coach.
I think the only advice I would give
is just not to trust any one of you.
(Kelly laughs)
- Why?
- A single word you say.
- We've been feeding her
lots of useful advice.
- Yeah, I'm sure, very useful.
- Totally.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- But she's gonna kill
it, she'll be great.
- Yeah, I thought, yeah,
you could at least warn her
about the one she's
probably gonna sit next to,
might be nice.
- All of you.
- She watches the show, though.
- Yeah, thoughtful.
- She knows.
- She does.
- She knows about Blake.
- She does watch the show!
- What does that mean?
What about me?
- Everybody knows about Blake.
Everybody knows.
- Lies and deception.
Okay--
- I just hope
I don't step on her.
- Are you? (laughs)
- Look at her, she looks so tiny on there.
- She is so tiny.
- [John] I think the friendship
between the two of you
will be substantial.
- Wow.
- I really hope she's
sitting right next to you,
it'll just look amazing.